[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm philip
molina and this is fitness origins a
fitness competition show inspired by the
movies of the mcu
except we are done with the in fitnessy
saga that part of our story is over and
this is now
the final episode of fitness origins
guys
i am legitimately blown away
that we kept this thing up as long as we
have three months
that's like half a baby or something i
really am
very very proud of both eric and tommy
for how much they've put into this
for 12 weeks or so now and the truth is
this show has been a
lot of fun but also like a lot of work
but that's kind of been the point
in real life fitness can be fun but yeah
it also takes work
and that's what this week is going to be
about let's bring the boys on and get
into it
hey guys how's it going good philip i'm
excited to get the challenge started i
feel like we've had a really solid
rehearsal
here these next 12 weeks are just gonna
fly by it's gonna be really something
no no no this has been it this is the la
this is the one time that you could say
that you're you're done and you don't
need any more
i think i'm good i think we're good here
well i think i'm done actually i hate to
sound like a broken record but i think
i'm good i think this goose is cooked
i think my fitness origins are over
oh i definitely one time i definitely
need more uh
much much more but we're we got a solid
base here come on
in all seriousness we feel good i feel
great
yeah i feel good uh i was worried the
way last week ended i didn't know the
difference between fiction and reality
i know it gets kind of blurred uh near
the end here
this is now real life everyone as real
life as youtube seems which
you know for all you know this is part
of the simulation and we only exist
because you're watching us
now what also is true though is that uh
tommy is
not totally wrong because in some ways
you both are getting started with your
fitness journeys if you think of it that
way then i'd say that maybe the show was
like training wheels actually
guiding you along uh keeping you from
falling down but honestly
we also just gotta take those training
wheels off and let you
ride out on your own now i hope that
three months of very
intense observation and public sharing
of your journey has been enough to
break some bad habits and hopefully
install some new
positive ones but i'm not ready to just
toss you to the wolves just here ah yes
you were trained by wolves i was raised
with them
i didn't see the domesticated dogs till
i was a man
you think the wolves are your allies but
yes
we are done with the marvel saga
but now this officially here now is
real life and as such
i want you to spend this week returning
to all the lessons we've learned each
week
of this show and figure out how you're
going to implement those lessons
for real into your lives in a permanent
way seriously
all the tools are there you have them
but it's up to you all to show
us how you're going to forever change
your lives
so that you never regress again i like
this idea before i was fighting against
my past self now i'm fighting against
future eric
who knows how jacked or lazy that eric's
gonna be
cause future eric has robot legs
and human legs you guys know your own
weaknesses and you know your own
excuses that you'll make so just find
ways
to preempt all of those problems
this week i'm not even going to track
your progress this week by the way
that's for you guys to do for yourselves
because that's what you're going to be
doing from
here on out okay don't fail me now app
that i definitely use
you know i would say this is my final
day one of the week but no this is like
the start of something new because
i feel like my body wants to do more so
in addition to doing the assigned hit
training i'm also scheduling some
weightlifting
just some moderate stuff to work my way
up to being able to
[ __ ] where's my body weight but i think
after this week is done
i'm still gonna hit most of these during
the week but on the days that i don't
i'm gonna
just diversify it up by doing some
weightlifting some days and then running
some other days
i think if i keep myself surprised i
should be able to uh keep myself excited
to work out every day
i'm going out for a jog i talked to some
of my family
about all 12 uh 12 weeks and what they
thought
all right mom what what's your overall
thought about what you saw
so proud of you and eric oh god and
philip
oh god and i was inspired by you
the fans are very inspired by you and i
can tell you're going to keep going with
this and
i think it's wonderful i thought it was
a fun journey
that i'm very proud of from the start i
tell you didn't want to do it but as the
weeks passed on i could tell you
like to do it more and more and it was
more fun what do you hope for the future
i hope for the future that you could be
strong
and finally defeat me okay
you can never defeat me perfect you know
i really think
exercise is part of my life now you know
i thank you to
phillip and and eric for encouraging me
and the part i gotta go under control is
the food now
so for the next few weeks i'm gonna keep
the exercise up and i'm gonna really
focus on my diet
all right i'm on my day two run oh
.76 miles in still feeling pretty good
i can totally do this every week totally
said that day three
is so hard look i would love to go
forward after this
never having to do a day three ever
again but realistically
i know these are good for me and some
part of me inside knows that this is
what my body should feel like
if i can do one of these once a week
plus some running plus some
weightlifting plus some of the other hit
training i'll set myself up to
push myself harder to burn more calories
every day the that
sounds pretty obvious i think it's time
to see just how strong i've gotten
with a series of physical and mental
[Applause]
one two on tests thank you philip thank
you eric
you've given me the strength for this
moment
[Laughter]
next push-up contest
all right work in progress last
challenge staring contest
happy friday fellas what a week how do
you guys
feel about your ability now to tackle
your fitness out in the real world
from here on out uh for me it was
weirdly
putting this out in the real world
because like i'm now
mixing up like i do the harder um hit
training
back in my rec room that i normally do
but now i'm mixing in some runs
throughout the week
and that sense of adventure is what
pulls me into the exercise
because who knows what uh scary dogs or
um uh crazy barbecues i'm gonna have to
run past
or like um or cars that are whizzing
past and surprise me
uh so that that call of the outdoors
call of the wild
uh is part of it but also um you know uh
my fiance kelly is a marathon training
right now so just this idea of being
able to run with her is
having a partner is a huge part of this
you know yeah tommy how are you gonna
keep
sharing your uh your progress uh well i
am also trying to get engaged to kelly
uh
no uh for me what's been helpful is inc
including my family my family is very
important to me and
they uh they've been joining along and
they want to continue to work out with
me so
having that accountability with them and
uh sharing with them
i also you know the outreach of people
that are fans of this channel
has i i felt that the entire time so i
kind of want to keep this public
legitimately that is that is really
great to hear uh
just how you know you guys are are going
to keep working i'm so
i'm so proud i am really glad to hear
that they that they did go pretty well
uh i think we got to give one last thank
you
to our sponsors for this show
doordash because without them we never
would have gotten this far but also
hopefully they gave you two a chance to
really
change your lives for the better for
sure did uh thank you mr doordash
uh wherever you are and thank you
gorgash
thank you both of you i'm looking
thinking back to where i was
during uh the early months of this year
throughout the holidays and
i was not on a good path in terms of
like my snacking
uh let's make them double doubles big
this time yes so having this opportunity
to just like
make this part of my job for a couple
months was uh
was really great i felt like it did kind
of kick start me to get in
some a good pattern of behavior so uh
obviously huge thank you to doordash for
the time being
doordash is sharing the love with all of
you too
uh for all of your cheat or non-cheat
meals with our special code
nerdfitness that gets you 25 off your
first order and zero delivery fees
uh as well but again that's only when
you use our code
nerdfitness on orders over 15 bucks eric
and tommy please tell the audience to
use the code
use the code god damn it please they're
taking my family
no no they have my wife no they don't
don't say that we're supposed to be
thanking them
oh sorry use nerd fitness i mean it's
cool guaranteed if you
punch in the code nerd fitness uh a lady
will also show up don't know
or a gentleman or someone of any uh uh
gender expression all right
fine hang on give me one more chance at
this guys just please use nerd fitness
for my sake for eric's sake
for god's sake yes for gorgash's sake
he's not doing well guys okay okay uh
that's a separate gofundme we'll get
into
at some point uh but they get it they'll
use the code
nerdfitness.doordash uh subject to
change in terms of ply
now one last thing guys we're all out of
challenges obviously uh
but we had to film a lot of this show in
this really
weird way because it's been during this
super weird time in history
and kovit has kept us apart for for most
of it we barely get to see each other
but now we are all officially fully
vaccinated
and i'm hoping you guys can just come
over to my place and we can
kind of just hang out i miss you guys oh
we'll miss you too yeah we'd love to i
miss you too i'll be there
by the way also um i'm not gonna gonna
train you guys obviously
we're done with that but i will work out
with you guys
let's load up the uh the day five video
and let's try to keep up with this
handsome devil
[Music]
damn nice house thank you
i decided now that we're here at the end
of the entire
saga i really have to step it up a notch
it's time
we move to phase four nice
of this housing subdivision wait what
what
i have been working you guys out for the
last three months to make you strong
enough so that you guys can help me move
to the new housing subdivision over
there you can't be serious
come on three months ago i asked both of
you to help me move and you both said oh
no it's too hard and we're not strong
enough
and you really left me in a bind so i
worked you guys out so you'd be strong
enough to do this
so the least you can do is help me move
how could you do this what do you mean
how could i do this to us look at you
guys you guys are so confident now and
slightly more attractive and i really
need you guys to finish this up in the
next hour or so
wait you're not even gonna help us come
on i'm a very important and busy man
also you keep forgetting about my
catastrophic toe injury
okay how long is this going to be an
excuse
don't shame him for his medical history
okay that's his business
we're better than that well he's healed
by now okay there he goes
well i don't know how we're gonna finish
this in time we'll do it together
but what if we fail
then we'll do that together too
what is this
rockstars these friends of yours eric do
they look like my friends
no clearly we got to beat these flag
smashers that must be the next challenge
okay i'm just going to say this one time
we got a lot of hands here we can knock
this move out in like 20 minutes
everybody grab a box sir if you'd like
to come help me with the box spring i
think we get this done
yeah who wants uh what
[ __ ]
i ain't bargaining
tell me look what i'm doing
whoa tommy we're not trying to kill
anyone oh sorry
oh sorry sorry
get awesome he's already dead
i'm not dead will you set this up papa
phillip
how could you i just wanted a
fun way to show you how far you guys
have come
to unlock the heroes inside of you well
we could have been
killed or really badly maimed but i
guess it's worth it
yeah totally worth it because now we are
officially heroes and all that's left to
do is celebrate
with one last cheat meal from our good
friends at doordash you can actually
save
25 percent i did not say there's no more
doordash budget
to get back on the ground you get it i'm
not shakes or choke outs you pick
fine one more door dash cheat meal
as long as you guys still [ __ ] help
me move of course we'll help you move
i mean we destroyed half of your
belongings it's the least we could do
i could do less correction you guys
can do anything fitness origin's
complete
[Music]
got to take a few weeks out of the
weight room now thanks to that karate
chop
my toes
[Music]
all right that is it for real this time
eric tommy i am so
so freaking proud of both of you
seriously i
also really really want to thank you for
letting me rope you two
into this and put it on the internet and
i know it was all so
incredibly weird to do on this channel i
know we know
but hopefully you guys got something out
of this
experience too yeah i think the biggest
thing i got out of it was um
you know the best way to try to get
healthier is to have a team with you so
tommy like you were the best partner to
go through this process with
uh and philip you were such a great
guide for all this like
if i just had to do this by myself i
never would have been able to do it but
having like uh the village here to keep
me keep me uh
on track was so crucial you were our
white wolf same
same i feel very fortunate you know you
guys have been my friends for a long
time
and you know you obviously care about me
and i uh
i feel very lucky to have friends that
want me to
get healthier because it's important to
me too so
eric i i echo your sentiment uh
getting to go along this process with
you was essential for me to be able to
stick
to it there are many times i uh
was discouraged and just a simple text
to you
whatever bad feeling i had and uh
monster from day one uh but like a lady
gaga style one
so like a little a little one yeah sexy
and a delicious oreo flavor but i
wouldn't know no phillip i
i really uh i really appreciate you
taking the initiative
to start this and i uh i feel very lucky
to have been a part of this
legitimately guys uh i've noticed it you
guys will both look different you guys
are both acting different your attitudes
are a little better um i i appreciate
all that so much
you guys have earned it we are upgrading
your trading card superhero stats
there you go that's right oh i'm gonna
sell those as nfts
yeah all right guys thank you again
so so much eric and tommy for
sharing this journey with us and being
so
vulnerable that's such a big part of why
this has been an inspiration to so many
people
i myself honestly i i'm headed back into
a fat burning phase i
put on more fat in the pandemic than i i
knew i would and i was kind of allowing
it
and then i overshot it so i'm now about
to head back into that burning phase
and honestly i'm personally inspired by
how hard you guys have worked
uh so i want to thank you guys too for
motivating me i
i mean like there's there's no reason
now that anybody should really
feel that this is kind of an alien
concept you guys have definitely
made it clear that it's just part of all
of our lives whether or not we're nerds
or not
also a huge thank you to everyone who
worked their asses
off to make this show happen supporting
me
eric and tommy were very very
hardworking
set designers producers editors stunt
coordinators
animal trainers fire breathers the
dallas cowboy cheerleaders uh and of
course uh doordash
and her friends at rooster teeth who
hooked us up uh with that as well
uh thank you guys so much to them yeah
very much
appreciate that i i would say all those
people's names what they've asked uh to
not be identified
all right guys that's it please
subscribe to epic hero fitness on
youtube because you know
this was just fitness origins but the
story will continue there
including my personal story of how i got
fit and why it was crazy hard for me and
took a lot of years
uh there also be fresh workouts on there
marvel star wars dc all kinds of
influences and fun ideas are headed uh
there i can't wait for you guys to see
what's coming so
once again it's epic hero fitness on
youtube uh please subscribe i have been
phillip molina
they have been eric boss and tommy
bechtold and this
has been our fitness origins bye bye
bye
[Music]
yeah yeah you thought we forgot about
that sweet sweet doordash cheat meal
and i finally got what i've always
wanted an
entire deep dish pizza chicago style
to myself yes oh
mother of jesus
hmm all i ever wanted
but i don't i don't want it i don't want
all of it anymore
what is this feeling what am i supposed
to do
with all this pizza
[Music]
[Music]
you